this is Bradley he is a big entrepreneur
on Tick Tock he's made many millions of
dollars and now he's kind of just
utilizing Tech talk marketing to his
advantage to blow up his businesses even
more this is similar to the agency that
I'm starting this is what we're going to
do for people basically what he has in
his accounts where it's him talking and
stuff
and it leads to business sales so if
you're a business person and you're
interested in working with me shoot me a
DM
this is what we do for you and help you
go viral but let's get into the video
how come people get married that's the
question I have you know that they end
in death or divorce correct everything
ends in death so come with that Brad
well a lot of times if you can't get
women it's because you don't value
yourself so like if I were truly going
to teach someone how to get a girl I
would teach them first how to Value
themselves because once you value
yourself authentically and really you
don't even want a woman it's like that's
not even important as soon as it's not
important they flock for some reason
it's weird when you want one man they're
not around and when you do find one
you're breaking getting in a bench for
them in a crowded bus you know but if
you value yourself you work on yourself
you build up that self-worth that
self-love as corny as that sounds and
that confidence you don't even want one
anymore and that's when they start
flocking facts that's so facts whenever
you're like looking to go out and find
girls and stuff never happens when you
go out with the mindset that you're like
I'm just going out
if there's a girl and we look at each
other then I'll talk to her yeah it's
way
God it's night and day feeling good
about yourself is everything it is just
you know having some confidence without
being an egotistical [ __ ] just having
your [ __ ] together feels good indeed and
people want to be around that
indubitably cheat when they're happy
because they're insecure they cheat when
they're happy because they have a hole
inside them they're trying to find the
value in themselves and the only way
they find Value is by dominating and
hunting down Primal instincts called sex
so they can't help themselves they want
to feel as if look I still have it
because when they're with somebody for
so long even though they're happy with
that individual it doesn't satiate their
void because they have a hole that will
not be fulfilled without work so they
cheat even though they're happy because
they're really trying to make themselves
feel worthy they're insecure their
insecurity is the problem that's really
why happy dudes cheat and or they're
just [ __ ] pigs now again I mean if
you ask me I value ethics right if
you're one of those dudes that are out
there pumping and cheating and you know
oh I was drunk honey sorry or can't help
who you love or hey it was just a quick
side piece it doesn't matter it doesn't
mean anything why do good men happy men
in their relationships cheat anyway well
they cheat because they have a hole that
they're trying to fill and they're
trying to remember that they're worth
something and they use I like to say
dominance because it's really you're
chasing women to satisfy a hole inside
you and be obviously
so he I I actually a hundred percent
agree with him
with women and men and people who cheat
that's like the complete opposite of
what Tate says but honestly I think Tate
now like he doesn't even like go around
again with a bunch of other girls
yeah he he indicated in one
one thing that we saw of him that he is
actually monogamous at least now I mean
that may have been a maturity thing but
I do think that everything that we we
hunt on this Earth that we think is
going to make us feel better about
ourselves is just a temporary fix like a
form of retail therapy if you will and
women are retail therapy for cheating
men
and
cheating women also trying to fill some
hole trying to fill some hole that
really if we go back to all the other
videos the only thing that fills that is
a spirit your your spirituality so
whether you're spiritual or God
that's the only thing that's ever going
to make you feel whole not jumping on
you know
that extra making another million
dollars is going to make you happy for a
minute going out and buying a new you
know fancy dress is going to make you
feel good for a minute but it's never
going to really fill the hole
never
so he's right and like he he did mention
in this video you know in ethics
ethics and I and I I how many times do
we talk about keeping your board
keeping your word it's hard to keep your
word
it's hard because some people like you
and I have a nature where we end up
biting off more than we can choose so we
set ourselves up to fail on keeping our
word on all the things to begin with
which is problematic
but some people it's not that's not even
their reason they're just weak and they
don't keep their word better
relationship stop being a dick
your relationship
to be in shape eat right and work out
you want to make more money meet more
people like dude it's not rocket science
but we all want to think that it is you
know why because it might make us feel
better that we're not already damn it
like softens the blow because if it was
easy now I'm a real loser I'm a loser if
it's easy so no it can't be that easy
and it is so true it's all about
Simplicity right yeah people people look
at like the micros and stuff so they're
fat or whatnot and it's like well you
eat like [ __ ] you don't work out for
starters start eating better food and
just going to the gym going on walks
take the stairs like you say
every right single person that we've
spoken to or reacted to
they say the same [ __ ] and they're all
successful it comes back to the same
[ __ ] thing keep it simple you've
heard the expression kiss
keep it simple stupid that's it that's
all you got to remember when you start
to get in your head and it gets
complicated and you get crazy and I
don't want to do this because it's
getting hard no well [ __ ] relax and
keep it simple and you'll see the
straight line between here and where you
want to go always yeah like people
always DM me how to make money online
and whatnot and it's like have you even
looked up what's what what is money have
you looked up like different money
making methods have you tried any of
them even if you try Drop Shipping or
some [ __ ] and it doesn't work out you
gain something out of it you realized oh
I started Drop Shipping I met this other
guy that was Drop Shipping but now he's
doing something else and he's making
more money off of that so even though
Drop Shipping didn't work out I'm gonna
go do that like you haven't even taken
any steps to do it all you've watched is
the [ __ ] Wolf of Wall Street
and then complain that you're not that
guy and it and you're right and even if
you do try something and it doesn't work
out what happens is some people say oh
it's all [ __ ]
everything I watch this video online and
I tried what the guy said and it didn't
work and it's all [ __ ] oh is it all
[ __ ] because there are a lot of
people out out here making a lot of
money and there's more money on this
planet for everybody to have a bunch of
it
some people are always going to have
more some people are always going to
have less but there is so much abundance
it is not that hard to get your piece
but [ __ ] crazy man [ __ ] excuses
and victimhood
budget if she wants something it's my
job to get if she wants something it's
my job to get it for her that's our deal
right she takes care of the kids she
does what she does I do what I do so if
she says Hey I want a new car
I should say voila but dude I feel like
that's my role I'm the breadwinner I'm
the hunter so she says I need this or I
need that it's like go like that's my
obligation yeah and it's not like he's
dating some some [ __ ] that's like I
need four cars give me this bag like I'm
sure he's dating a good woman that does
her role and then also gets a pizza to
buy I mean I think that's totally normal
I saw a video on Twitter the other day
of a girl saying something similar like
that and everyone was roasting her in
the comments
because she was saying her husband's
money is kind of hers and like to an
extent I guess is it is it not like if
that's your partner if she's staying
home all day and you're taking care of
her like if she wants something I mean I
could be wrong like but if if that if
she's doing her role and your role is to
make the money are you gonna get mad at
her for not having enough money to go
buy something she wants you know what I
mean it depends on so if you're a man of
abundance and you have a woman who isn't
taking advantage of that then absolutely
yeah she wants something make it happen
or if you have the ability make it
happen but
if you have some using [ __ ] who's
bleeding you're dry no matter how much
you make she ain't satisfied you gotta
cut that broad loose no yeah and it's
very important to make that distinction
though than just buying girls everything
they want yeah [ __ ] that no you gotta
you gotta we all have to earn our keep
one way or another
for real man cut them off shut them out
cut them off shut them out don't even
worry about them if they're threatened
by your success in my opinion they're
not your friends and they're not your
family just because you're related by
blood doesn't make you a family just
because you got blood pumping through
your veins the same that makes you
related
doesn't make you family when they begin
to become threatened by your success you
need to set them down and have a
conversation you sit them down and let
them know that under no circumstance
will you allow anyone to derail anything
that's going on and if they don't jump
on board enthusiastically you'll have to
cut them off for a while so if they're
all bummed out and pissed off that I'm
succeeding I got news for them I'm not
changing just to please them cut that
was a
that's a good point though I mean if
there's family that's toxic I mean you
can't just like because they're family
just stick with them forever
they're shitty people yeah I agree I
just I just I want to be clear to not be
flip about it you know family he'll say
just because you're you know you got the
same blood you're related you're not
family you know you are family you are
and maybe that's a cultural thing I
don't know what his well you work to get
over stuff upbringing is and what his
nationality is like We are family and
when my family pisses me off
if I found out that they really needed
something even if you haven't talked to
them because I want to choke them out
I'm showing up and when something goes
wrong with the people I'm even you know
people I'm close with in my family no
matter how inconvenient it is for me I'm
showing up so to me I yeah you gotta you
gotta distance
from the toxic ones in your family but
cutting them out is is something I I
can't quite get behind hmm
yeah but it's I mean I guess I just
looked at it differently like I I kind
of thought the same thing as you like
you're not just like deleting them out
of your life forever but you don't have
to spend as much time with them or
surround yourself with them if they're
toxic and they don't have a good impact
on your life right right no one toxic no
one toxic belongs in your daily life
period a good woman can outspend your
income you need to go look in the mirror
and [ __ ] take responsibility that
you're not making enough everybody
didn't like that if she's out spending
your income you need to make more money
but I prefaced it with if you have a
good girl because a good woman would not
outspend your [ __ ] income she
would respect the fact that you only
made X and she would be [ __ ] happy
you know living within that a shitty
woman
wouldn't give a [ __ ] because she's out
for herself totally selfish she'll spend
all your money and and as soon as you're
broke she'll find someone else right so
if a good woman's outspending your
income it just probably means you're not
really making that much because a good
woman isn't gonna take advantage you
know say you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year or whatever I
don't know that's not the right thing so
say say there's a 500 a week like
you know and it that also includes you
know some Basics and and extra treats
if she's doing that and you're not
keeping up with it
she's not out by trying to buy a ten
thousand dollar purse she's out just
like maybe like you said wanting to get
a yoga class or something like go make
some more money up your game kid but if
she's good and she's loyal and she's
taking care of all the things like
supporting your life he's so right about
that how can you be disciplined when you
got a set of man boobs you can't and if
you have fat on yourself it's just a
choice
you think he had man boobs
he did in the first video we watched I'm
just saying and maybe he was having a
bad month
but you know
I mean it looks like he's in pretty good
shape
he does he's he's an attractive man but
he had man boobs in the first video what
are you gonna do all right imagine
you've decided to have fat on your body
you've made that choice because
sometimes when you're like I didn't
choose it yeah choosing not to do
anything about it is choosing to have it
so again I mean I still have fat on me
I'm probably 15 body fat 16 body fat I'm
still on my way to double digits but I
can promise you this whether it takes
one year or 10 years there is no
stopping it's a lifestyle now it's the
way I do things how can you be
disciplined he's on the track to get to
single digits or or I I thought he was
saying it's a lifestyle to have some fat
um also a choice and it's fine but as
long as you acknowledge that this is
your choice in your in your own and
let's be honest with ourselves I agree
with them though like there's people
that like specific Life Choices or
opinions they have make me like
genuinely not want to do business with
them because I judge them you know what
I mean I'm freaking broke I don't feel
like I'm being broke I don't want to be
broke how can you never be broke again
I'll tell you how you can never ever be
broke again you take a hundred dollar
bill you fold it up and you put it in
your wallet and you don't touch that son
of a [ __ ] ever
because it's only there to let you know
that you're not broke that's how you can
be never broke again go to 100 bill in
your wallet and leave it there okay
never touch it it's simply there for
mindset purposes that way you know you
can never be broke and as soon as your
mindset wraps around the idea that you
can never be broke you start moving
towards an abundant mindset and you
start leaving the scarcity space so I
don't have a hundred dollars I'm broke
okay find the penny
work for twenty dollars stick twenty
dollars in your pocket can I get a come
on I like that yeah I like that too it's
a mind game and it's a it's a gimmick
but I like it I think there's value in
it and I think that that really does
change your mindset you know if people
like you know if you'll go down and
spend down to your last dollar to go
hang out with your friends and go to the
club or whatever over and over and over
again yeah you're going to stay broke
but if you've got that hundred and your
friends are like we're gonna go out and
you're just like nah I'm good I'm gonna
I'm gonna stay home and you have it in
your head that you're not doing it
because you don't because you have the
power over that and your home with your
100 bucks I mean yeah and then there's
like the YOLO people who'll be like come
on man you only once let's go they're
not living they're not really living
they're all living down to their last
dollar too all right thank you guys for
watching make sure to follow myself and
my mom on Instagram Sonny Faz and
Sonny's mother and join the Discord I
have some free social media tips for you
guys to go viral first if you like this
video drop us up on YouTube